Hey, what's going on? It's bill burn.
It's time for the Monday
morning podcast for Monday,
July 4th,
2016 how's it going?
Happy Birthday to of the
United States of America.
Happy Birthday to the
Happy Birthday. United States of
America and the North American car.
Turn and
happy birthday to you.
What's going on?
And I'll thank you for the well wishes.
Happy Birthday from all the
other countries around the
world that realize we are
the best. Huh? You think
you got fat people? Huh?
Take a look at that.
Beat that mother fuckers.
What else do you think he can
beat us in? Huh? What do you want?
What do you want to have it? What do you,
what kind of fucking battle you want? Oh,
you can around the world. You stole our
genes. All those cool American Jane's.
You guys would defect from your country
just to get over here to get a pair of
button. Fly fucking five oh one blues.
Remember that shit all of a sudden,
you know,
couple of fucking wars and everybody
forgets how much you love dark jeans.
That's, you know what, that's just
typical. That is just fucking typical.
You know,
fucking England coming over here steel
and it re fucking Cyclin are fucking
music walking around like
they're doing something,
redoing the fucking music from
the people that we didn't accept.
Fuck are you guys do it? Um, anyways,
um,
I'm having a great three day weekend.
I'm not doing shit. I am, uh,
I'm back in the workout mode so the
needle is pointed in the right direction.
Oh, freckles is going, Dad, Dad,
dad fucking looked in
the mirror last night.
I could tell I was starting
to lose weight, maybe feel
good. You know what I mean?
That's, it's a fucking tough
thing being a redhead, you know,
use a really small window that you have
to exist in or else the beating start
again and it's really something
you can understand. Um,
all right, I'm all over the fucking
place. I got a bunch of Shit I have to do.
I'm having some family over
today for a fucking cookout.
I'm going easy this year rather than
trying to smoke something and blah, blah,
Blah and do all that shit.
I'm just fucking go on burgers and dogs,
burgers and dogs the way it used to be
before the fucking food network showed up
and everybody's got to be like a top chef.
You know? Remember you were growing up.
That's what it was.
It was burgers and dogs and everybody
was fucking happy right till the booze
started coming around and then,
yeah, and it got a little sideways.
But I mean it happens.
So, uh, yesterday, um,
had some friends over, we had
some cigars, right? And uh,
you know the deal, it's like, all
right, your buddies are coming over,
you're wife's going to be like,
how are they going to bat? Um,
even if they're cool,
like my wife's cool,
but there's always going to be in
element of, Hey, are you going to bear?
They're going to be loud. They're
going to be upstairs and as, Huh?
It's like, yeah, I'm having
people over. Do I do that?
When you have a little twice,
do I?
You have them over for the fucking wines
and you're all sitting there laughing
with your high pitch fucking voices.
You don't think that that's put
in cracks in the walls? I don't,
I don't fucking bitch about it. I go
down to the old fucking hardware store.
I get out to spackle. Right? Okay.
Well with Debbie little cat,
go write another fucking line in the wall.
You don't hear me complain and got my
putty knife out. Oh, you have a good time,
ladies. Right. Um,
anyways, uh, so we have, we were, uh,
hanging out with actually
fucking hilarious because
I'd gone out and I bought,
you know, got some Cuban cigars. I want to
fuck it. I cleaned everything up. Right.
The thing that,
what you want to do,
this is what I've realized when you live
in with a woman, which you want to do,
is you just go all out. Right? You
fuck, I cleaned the fucking place up.
Okay. I even like, like
the deck on the back,
like I fucking hosted off.
So they wouldn't be traipsing dirt in
and out of the house or whatever. Right?
And she's sitting there going like,
wow, you're really going all out. Yeah.
There's a reason Sam Kinison,
there's a fucking reason.
There's a fucking reason why.
Because what you want to do is what you're
doing is you just put yourself into a
position where you did
absolutely nothing rock.
So when they complain,
cause there's still going to complain.
You got all of this fucking Amall right?
I cleaned this whole fucking place up,
right? Cleaned out the back porch down
the backyard, the whole fucking thing,
cleaned it up.
And we're having family over here today,
which was another great one to be like,
well I'm also doing it for your family,
right? So, um,
I'm doing all of this shit.
I got,
I got the boots,
I got the fucking thought,
the outdoor patio furniture.
I got everything all cleaned up.
I got an ash tray upstairs.
I've got one downstairs.
I got the backyard lights on. I got the
whole fucking thing, I got the music,
I got the whole thing.
And then it like six o'clock at
night I realized I didn't get cigars.
I bought cigars,
but I don't have a humor door.
And I said I was going to pick them
up and I had this fucking panic attack
because it was Sunday before the fourth
that they were going to close and it was
six excruciating rings
before they picked up.
And I was able to run down there
and get them right. And um,
they showed up, I ordered some
pizzas and all that fucking shit.
And here's the best part,
right here was the best part.
I, my wife went to
sleep, right? We smoking,
we're telling fucking stories, you know,
I got all these orange sodas for myself,
right?
And I turns out everybody there wanted
one because it had the real sugar and it
went great with the cigar.
I'm telling you,
Cuban Cigar in the fantail
orange soda is the Shit, right?
They drank all my orange soda.
So I had to drink grape soda like a
fucking six fucking year old, right? So,
um, anyways, the end
of the night it own it.
I fucking cleaned up everything. You
wouldn't, you wouldn't even fucking know.
You wouldn't know a guide
that you wouldn't know that
a fucking soul was here.
And that's what you do. All these fucking
married guys who sit there, you know,
it's that back and worth it. It
is fucking worth it. It just,
you just have to do it
perfectly, right? You go all out,
you clean up the fucking place,
they come over,
you have a great fucking time.
When you leave,
you fucking cleaned the whole
place up against what can she say?
What is she going to say to you?
You're not allowed to have friends.
Um,
little things like that,
cause I've had buddies in my coming
over here like on dude, you fucking,
what are you doing? You did all that and
you're fucking wash the dishes. It's,
there's a, there's a genius behind
what I do. I'm talking shit here.
I'm drinking throat coat
tea and I'm talking shit.
What can they fucking say? Then what it
is is if you do everything perfectly,
then they're leaving
themselves totally exposed.
If they start complaining that they're
all that basically can complain about it
at that point is that you have friends
and you invited them over to the house.
All right? And they know they don't
have a fucking leg to stand on.
So the bitch and goes down by like 90%
now if you have your fucking friends over
and you leave the fucking ash tray out
and there's footprints all over the
fucking place, they can make it
about that when the real thing is,
is they don't want you to have friends,
right?
But they can hide behind the other shit.
But then the real thing is they don't
want you to have friends and they want to
slowly kill you so that they can, you
know, have the house to themselves.
And if you, you know,
go to the obituaries,
there's a bunch of guys dropping
around 58 59 60 and that,
that's what happened.
What really happened was they had
friends over and they didn't clean up,
you know, which gave their wives the
window to bitch them into an early grave.
And now they're sitting there in the
fucking house having a hell of a time,
right?
Getting to play the victim,
getting all the sympathy cards
and eating all the poundcake.
And that's a fact, you know, come in
with the truth here in the 4th of July.
Hannah at the fuck I'm talking
about anyways, so afterwards, right?
So we're drinking sodas.
I'm stone sober, right? And
everybody leaves except for one of my
other buddies. And um, he wasn't an AA.
Right? The older you get, the more
your friends fucking, they quit.
You know what I mean?
They just fucking quit.
It's like being a lifer in the military.
Everybody doesn't sign back up.
All of a sudden you're the old guy,
you know,
fucking walking around where it out. Fuck
all my friends go. Right. Walking around.
All Sad.
But you fucking smokey the bear hat.
All right. Hey you. Um,
so he still drinks so they leave.
So I get out to giant fucking ice cubes.
A poor couple of Johnny blue,
right.
And uh, you know, he has to drive. So
He's, he's doing a little sippy cup shit.
And I live here, so I'm doing the
home porch, right. Thousand 1000,
2003 seat, right. One of those ports.
So I have a couple, two, three of those.
I'm feeling good. And, uh, you know,
but I'm not, I cleaned the whole fucking
dude when I say I cleaned the whole, the,
all the leftover pizza.
I wrapped each slice individually and
foil and then I put a letter on it.
Pay for Pepperoni,
s facade sausage m for fuck in.
Margaret took the pizza boxes out,
put them in the recycle Bin,
took out the fucking chemicals,
fucking spray down the counters.
You wouldn't fucking do that.
God Damn forensic team of forensic cards
with their fucking dusters would come
in, would have no fucking
idea anything happened. Right?
So now I'm feeling all proud of myself.
I got my little fucking sippy drink
there and I put on the TV cause I'm not
ready to go to bed yet. And what do
I see? Time life books or whatever.
Time-Life records presents. Easy
listening. Love songs. Right?
And I'm sitting there watching
it, right? I'm not in love.
Don't fuck it. Asked me a pitch.
Put Your picture on the wall,
cause it to stay there. Right. I'm like,
I remember that fucking song and
we'll can forget this one angle.
Bird Hopper,
Dick,
please roll.
Geez. Do you ever listen to the lyrics
of that song? It's like, for fuck's sake,
just break up with her. He goes, says
something like, I've talking about,
I found a new love.
Her lips are warm and yours is so cold.
It's like angled park.
Just enough with the fucking details.
Just break up with you. Your just say,
look, I'm not in love with you anymore.
You know, going to bring up the
other fucking broad down the street.
Just got your heart racing. You
fucking cunt. It's such a country song.
But you know,
I heard it when I was younger,
so I'm listening to all
of these fucking songs.
God doesn't make little green apples
and fucking something, something babble.
And next thing you know,
I'm on the phone calling one
800 gimme those fucking cds.
So the guy picks up the phone and he goes,
Hey,
this is rob from time live records. Who
Am I speaking too? Let's see, I'm blank.
You speaking of Bell, rob, how you
doing buddy? Got Abdu it. Great.
Uh, what, what, uh, what can I do
you for? I'm like, well, you know,
I'm watching ankle bearcomm predict
given this broad too much information.
But uh, you know, I like the sound
of it. I want to order the CDS.
And he goes, great, great. Can I
get a phone number? I'm like, no,
you can't not giving you my phone number.
He goes,
well then I can't complete this order.
Just like that.
Like I was the 90th
person in a row that said,
I'm not giving you my phone number.
Okay.
Right. And he was tired of hearing. He
just went, he gave me the old right there,
Fred. Well they're like,
can't do the order.
Is there anything else I can help
you with? And I'm like, Whoa Way Rob.
Well what's going on?
We just went from zero to 200 here.
Why do I have to give you my phone number?
And he's like,
oh you have to get phone numbers so
we can complete the order. It's like,
I understand you're saying that but
I'm asking you why. And he goes,
oh it's cause it's company policy.
And I'm like,
why is it company policy if he goes,
because I need the phone number in
order to complete the order. I go, okay.
See what we just did there? We
just drove in a circle. Okay,
I'm trying to get out of the centrifical
fucking force here and get over to the
reason the fucking racing.
Right.
Okay.
And he finally just goes, well, you know,
the reason is that if it's a problem
with your order, we need to to call you.
And it's just like, well, if
there's a problem with the order,
meaning you charging my card in the
cds, don't ever come. You don't think,
I'm not going to call you. You get
literally had, when I called up,
if there's a problem with your order,
press two.
So he just, can we just keep
going round and round? I go,
you just want the phone number and I go,
not you personally, but time life does.
So they can sell it to other people.
Next thing you know, I'm walking,
my dog had some Qantas calling
me up going, congratulations,
you're the lucky business
winter of whatever, right?
So it fucking escalates to
a really hostile, you have
a good night, sir. I'm like,
Yo, I have a good night
to rob, right? Hang Up.
And I'm sitting there for a second,
right? Doing the whisper, yelling,
fucking cocksuckers they can fucking
stupid enough to give you my phone number,
right? All by myself. Look like
a complete lunatic, you know?
And in the background, the fucking
commercial still on Muskrat, the
amps in that fucking cock
sucking mother fuckers. Right?
Just fucking send me the fucking shit.
I bought this before.
I never had to give you my phone number.
Three easy payments of 29 95.
Right? You get my fucking money.
You gonna call me up page.
It's this rob who time, life,
just calling to check to see
if he got those cds, right?
So anyways, um, I really
want these fucking cds.
So I called back again and for some
reason I just started to just go into a
southern accent.
And I was like,
when they asked me for their phone number,
I'm just for my phone number,
I'm just going to give them their
number. See if they, they notice like,
can I get your phone number? Sure. What
800. Right. I was going to do that shit.
But uh, what happened was by the
time the lady picked up there,
it was the end of the infomercial, it
went on to something else. You know,
something that me then makes you skinny
or fucking helps clean up after you
goddamn kids. I forget what it was. Right?
So she, she answers the phone. She's like,
Hey, this is so blah, blah blah blah blah
from fucking time. I'm like, I don't,
I liked the order them a easy listening.
Uh,
Sadie's five easy payments of 29,
nine to five. She's like, okay,
can I get a name? Who Am I speaking
to? Unlock Bill. Bill Burr,
right. Just totally, it does
not sound like a southern name.
Whatever southern and Joe, Bill Burr. Um,
okay.
And uh, she goes, can
I get a phone number?
I just decided I was just going to
give her area coach. I was like,
my phone number is eight one eight
three two, three, two, one, two,
five [inaudible]. And she goes, okay,
that number is a 183-TWO-THREE-2125.
I'm like, yes it is. Yes ma'am.
Just lied. I got my tapes.
They're going to fucking show up,
right my cds. No fucking problem.
Okay.
I gave them a fake email,
like I said,
too damn tall@aol.com
and you're what that means.
Can I get an email arts?
It's a two the number two
number two and d a m n tall.
Like I didn't say damn like I was trying
to be polite so then she had to read it
back.
So that email is number two
d a m n tall@aol.com I like,
that's right.
Yes it is.
And I got him common five fucking cds,
five CDs for 30 bucks. Three
payments. I don't know what the fuck.
What is this going to be? A lot
of cds. You know what's funny?
My Prius still has a CD holder.
What my new car gets here at won't
and then what the fuck do I do? Well,
I know and I do. I sell them for one easy
payment of nine 95 on Ebay, you know,
and no phone numbers required.
Just give me a fucking address and I'll
send it to you when you think about that.
All right, come on bill. Type in your
fucking pass without Jesus Christ.
So rumor has it,
the Kevin Durant is going to go to
the fucking Golden State Warriors.
Okay.
And as a sports fan, I cannot think
of a more boring fucking move.
You know what I mean?
Okay.
I fucking hate how ESPN and
all these sports places,
they just don't call him out on it.
Like how bad that is for sports fans.
Okay.
I wanted to see if Oklahoma City, now
he hasn't done it yet, but you know,
sources say rumors and all that shit. I
wanted to see if you know, what the fuck
can Oklahoma City get by
golden state next year. Good.
Golden state redeemed themselves and
when a fucking championship, you know
it was such a great series,
exciting series.
Oklahoma had a beat,
they had their foot on the neck and then
fucking golden state comes roaring back.
And this is like, this is great. I
want to see this again next year.
Like when the 76 has tried
to get past the Celtics,
Dr Jay didn't just sign with the Celtics.
Granted they got Moses Malone.
I guess it's been going on for awhile.
I just don't fucking get it. Still fucking
get it. It's like, all right, these,
this is a great rivalry.
They're evenly matched.
It went seven games.
Hey,
let's take the best player
or one of the best players,
depending on if you like Westbrook prayer
and we'll just stick them on the other
fucking team.
And now that rivalry is null and void.
Now it goes from wow seven game,
great series to fucking, you know,
four or five game series.
Who gives a shit?
I don't fucking get it. It's
fucking Jerry West going, you know,
if he, if you sign here, you're, you're
rebounding is going to be modus more.
Your blurb of blood can be a chair.
You don't give a fuck.
You don't give a fuck if it's all the
best players in the league are all on one
fucking team. It's, it's the worst
fucking thing ever. You know,
this is coming from a Celtic fan. And
I watched us do that. What that Kevin,
Kevin Durant, Kevin Durant, Kevin
Garnett team. You know, they,
we just bought that we went from
literally last place to winning the
championship and one fucking year.
And I realized that there's a skill to it,
but as a crabby old
fucking curmudgeon, um, I,
I just don't, I just, what is
exciting about that? If he go,
if he signs with the Golden State
Warriors, well that's great.
Why don't you have Lebron jump on that
one to remember those great Miami Heat
teams. Remember how exciting
that was if you lived in Miami?
Everybody else.
So it was a fucking snooze fest.
They'll sit on a fucking yacht.
Hey,
y'all want to be on the same team
will win three in a row and we'll,
we'll be like, we'll be a dynasty. Like
the fucking the bulls. We'd be like them.
Yeah. Except they didn't
pile on. Oh, I'm in a mode.
I hope that moved doesn't happen. You
know, it's going to happen. I just, uh,
you know, whatever, it's his fucking
career. But just saying as a sports fan,
as a guy who fucking watches sports but
doesn't really pick up on anything and
then runs his fucking
mouth than a podcast,
I am not in favor of that fucking move.
That would suck,
you know? Yeah. It just, what,
what, what are you gonna do?
Well, that's what they, that's what these
kids do nowadays. I mean, we're actually,
it's been going on for 30
fucking years. Biggest, um,
I guess free agent signing or trade or
whatever of my life of my life was a
Wayne Gretzky.
Yeah.
Go into the kinks.
If ever there wasn't an unmovable guy,
like there's no fucking way this
franchises ever getting rid of this player
unless we just completely, I dunno, went
out of business folded and had to move.
Or if our, uh, I don't know,
our owner's son fucking, uh, finance,
the Michael Jackson victory tour,
you know, so now daddy has to sign,
sell the fucking team because
Michael Jackson stage was so big at,
ate up all these fucking seats that
they were losing money every night.
And then racist Massachusetts said
that they couldn't do the show out in
Foxborough,
you know,
cause they didn't want a bunch of black
people coming out to Foxborough mass
going, hey, for fucking three hours.
Evidently that was going to be a problem.
I could see then making the fucking move.
All right. Do you know that I promoted,
told me that that's how I always used
to think that when Billy Sullivan,
the original owner of the Patriots,
his son Patrick,
somehow was the promoter for the Michael
Jackson victory tour. And I remember, um,
at the last second, you know, it was
supposed to be at Sullivan Stadium,
which is what's a Patriot's old stadium.
And um,
at the last second Foxborough
was just like, yeah, no,
you're not having that concert out here.
And it was just because it was gonna be
a bunch of black people out there. Right.
And, uh, but Michael Jackson had in his
contract that, you know, once you sign it,
whether the show happens and not,
you gotta pay me.
And I used to think that that
one show fucked him over.
But this promoter in Boston told me,
no,
he had this giant ass fucking stage and
the Sullivan's didn't take into account.
This is all alleged here of the amount
of seats that that was going to take up
in the arena, you know, and uh,
and they didn't realize that
when they were making the deal,
they were calculating a certain number
of seats versus what they would play in
the Jacksons and it all worked out.
And then when they saw the behemoth of a
fucking stage, they will let go. My God.
So they go to Michael, they're like,
Michael, he was like, yes. They were like,
can you make your stage a little smaller?
We're going to lose our shirts here.
And Michael Jackson was like,
no, I, if, if I have it smaller,
prince is going to outdo me.
Like he had like, you know,
that rivalry with Tim going on.
I don't know if that's fucking true.
Somebody told me this story and then I
just repeated it as fact. I mean this,
this is what I do on the podcast.
I'm just running my up
here. Uh, did anybody watch,
did you watch the Austrian Grand Prix?
If that didn't make you a
fucking formula one racing fan?
Holy Shit.
That was like fucking days of
actually tweeted that yesterday,
dude. It's like, okay,
this is the deal. The German
team, the Mercedes Benz, right?
They got Nico Rosberg and Lewis Hamilton.
All right.
Nico Rosberg is a German,
right?
Lewis Hamilton is, uh, he's
from England, right? And uh,
evidently from the isle of Man,
from what people were texting
tweeting me the other day.
So Nico is ahead.
He's,
he's beaten everybody in
the points in the standings.
And Louis is like the fucking
upstart guy, I guess. I Dunno. Right?
He wears the big fucking diamond
chain, you know what I mean? He's from,
he's from England. I don't know what is,
is, is racist. I don't know if he's mixed.
I don't know what his deal is. And he's
got the bling going on and all this shit.
So all the old fucking,
um,
traditional fans of the
sport, traditional wink, wink.
I like the Old School Formula
One, wink, wink. Right.
You know what that fucking means?
They don't like this guy.
Evidently they don't like is blamed.
They don't like his,
you know his whole item. Boise, I dunno,
I don't want to fucking
throw the ugliness in there,
but it seems like there's a little
issue there. Right. So anyways,
earlier this year I guess to the Spanish
Grand Prix, I didn't see that one.
They both fucking,
they banged into each other.
Nico was coming around the corner and
he's pushing buttons on that playstation
steering wheel, whatever the
fuck that thing is. You just,
you just have a fucking stairwell. Then
it was a steering wheel with the paddles.
Now it looks like a little game boy and
they're pushing shit to fucking conserve
energy and I don't,
I don't know what the fuck it is.
But they somehow do this going like 180
miles an hour, which is amazing to me.
Hundred 20 miles an hour and a fucking
turn as if did dealing with the g forces
of slowing down and taking a turn.
Well over a hundred miles an hour.
This sitting there on a fucking
pushing buttons, you know,
like texting while driving
fucking doing this shit.
So earlier in the year
they had one, uh, you know,
Hamilton tried to pass him on the
inside and then Nico was defending his
position or whatever the fuck he said.
He came over, he put Lewis on the fucking
grass, he spun out, he clipped
the back end Nico's car,
they slammed into each other and uh, they
both got the old, the old right there,
Fred the DNC, right. Did
not complete the race,
which caused a Mercedes a
bunch of fucking points.
So evidently they probably sat them
down and was like, Hey, fuck heads,
you're on the same team here.
What?
Say you don't knock each other
out of the race. So whatever.
They got this whole rivalry going and it
seems like Nico thinks he's the fucking
guy. And Louis is this like, well, I know,
you know, I respect that you're the guy,
but I'm trying to be the guy too,
so go fuck yourself.
So yesterday they're
fucking racing and uh,
uh, you know, I don't
know much about the sport,
but evidently there's soft tires and
if the soft tires aren't soft enough,
they got super soft tires.
And I guess the softer your tires are
depending on the weather condition,
the faster your car goes.
So whatever fucking reason they give
Nico the super soft ones and they give
Lewis just to soft ones so they're fucking
them over with each lap. All right.
So Nico's obviously the golden child
that the corporate guys like and Louis is
the fucking upstart, right?
He's the Tom Cruise. Okay.
The other guys to fucking established
Kahn who's winning. Right.
I'm just guessing all of this
shit. So, um, I dunno it,
something about the pitstop
Lewis was slower than Nico's.
They gave all the fucking, its advantage
to Nico Cause Nico's went in the points.
I think that they want him to win the
fucking race cause they want to win the
championship and Louis
wasn't fucking having it.
So he's driving like a fucking maniac
on soft tires when Nico's got this super
soft and next thing you know
he's right on his fucking ass.
It's the last lap of the fucking race
and Louis goes to pass him
on the outside of the turn,
taking the long way around. He's on,
he's fucking ties or on the white line,
he can't get over any father
if he's going to pass.
If you see he's going to
overtake them on the final lap,
the fucking announcers are going nuts. It
fucking, Nico just drove right into him.
He said he had a breaking
problem. It's like, Oh yeah,
did you have a staring problem to you?
Fucking drove right into him
and it's like, oh my God,
they're going to knock each
other out of the race again.
And they get out of it and then they
came back together and then fucking I,
I think the back of Hamilton's car clipped
the front of a Rosberg's and took us
little fin fin things off the front.
So now he can't drive fast and when your
car's damaged like that and you'll blow
and debris all over the track.
I didn't realize this.
Evidently you're supposed to pull over.
He supposed to hit the old rest area.
Just be like,
well,
I guess we're going to call it a day
because all that shit that you're putting
in the track and blow out
somebody's tire caused him to crash.
They could get injured and they're
not going to fucking finish.
And it's not their fault that you
fucking drove into your teammate.
But this con keeps driving his car,
shrapnel all over the track. And
he finished, he got penalized.
Long story short was Lewis Hamilton and
then went in the fucking race and uh,
they were cutting to the,
uh,
whatever the owners of the Mercedes
team and they're all fucking pissed.
And uh, one of the guys on the Mercedes
teams is the guy that, you know,
went for that movie rush.
I should really have the guy's name here.
I'm new to this sport,
so forgive me for not knowing his name.
The Guy who had that horrific crash on
the Ferrari team in 1976 and he had the
fire, they showed it in a, that movie
rush. She was absolutely terrifying.
And what's more terrifying, they'd
being alive on fire, you know?
Okay.
What would you rather be alive on fire
or in the ocean watching a great white
shark approaching. Yeah. No, no one.
It's going to fucking take you leg off.
I mean,
I actually think you got
to go with the shark.
Just fucking bite my leg off.
Does a major artery right there.
I'm going to fucking be like,
ha.
And then the dopamine is going to come
out and I'm having that goofy smile on my
face is the hammer head comes
into, finish me off. Right?
So anyways, they would to me afterwards,
Nico said that he had a break in problem.
I don't know.
I don't fucking know.
So now there's all these conspiracy
theorists out there going like, well,
you know, it's the German team.
Nico's a German. All right,
fucking Hamilton's,
uh,
you know,
from England and he doesn't look like
you're fucking English guy being made.
And he's not a white dude. Maybe there's
some racism going on there. I don't know,
but I just became a hit Lewis
Hamilton fan. I still like Ross spark,
you know he's racing, he's out there,
you know, you can't fucking handle it.
He's one of those,
he seems like one of those guys you ever
to go out and you play like pickup who
per pick up hockey and it's just some
fucking nice guy and all of a sudden the
game starts and they get that
fucking look in their face.
Like they'll blow out a knee just to
score a goal. You know those lunatics,
you just sitting there going like,
all right,
I'm going to fucking steer clear slash
try to annoy the shit out of this person.
Going to try to make sure this guy
doesn't fall on my fucking leg. You know,
I had a buddy of mine, right? Fucking
nicest guy ever. He's a psychiatrist.
He works with troubled inner city youth
who just gone through all kinds of
fucking horrific shit. He has the
patience to sit there, you know,
and work with these kids that are acting
out because of all this horrible stuff
that's happened to them in their home
life and he sits there and he handles it
and he loves it. You fucking get that guy
out on the ice. He's a fucking lunatic.
One time I took the,
we mean the other guy,
we'd fucking taking the
puck away from him and he,
I heard his breathing change and he just
fucking brought his stick up and I'm
telling you about, this is why I
wear the full birdcage, right dude,
45 degree angle across my whole face.
It just Bam.
It hit my fucking cage and I looked
at it. I was just like, dude,
what the fuck up for whatever dumb reason,
I was one of those people,
you know that comes out, please
pick up hockey only wearing a visor.
Those guys alluded six,
especially when,
because there's always the person
out there that can't skate,
which is usually me,
and you start doing that run in place.
I'm going to fall forward. I'm going to
fall back. I'm going to fall forward.
And you've got like the stick in
your hand that's coming up and taking
somebody's teeth out. So, um,
oh my God, what a lunar, I mean,
I literally would have needed like fucking
plastic surgery that was kicking off
fucking face like mine. You just ride it
out. Oh, there's this name right there.
I got it right there and I'm sorry. Uh,
Nikki, I'm going to say it wrong. Lau Da.
I don't know how to say Lotta I sweat.
So he was,
they talked to him and I'm looking at
this guy looking like the old race and guy
like one of his ears. It's like, you
know, mostly burned off and shit.
He's got the scars on the side of
his face. I gotta be honest with you.
He looked pretty fucking bad ass,
you know what I mean?
And another guy named, I swear
to God, Toto Wolff total,
like the band I went up.
That's on the CDS.
[inaudible] in a way. It could
be in the moment. It is the,
um, all right, let's do a
couple of reads here. Oh, Jesus.
It was 32 fucking minutes.
It just running my Yap or simple faith.
We have somebody new here.
Everybody's simple faith.
Thousands of people seeking home security
get ripped off every day at the home
security industry and,
and the home security industry wants
you to believe it's your only option.
They got hold
of salesmen out there trying to scare
you into signing one of their longterm
contracts.
You get stuck writing huge checks
month after month with capital letters.
No way out.
Okay?
It's robbery by contract and
it can cost you thousands,
but there's a better way to
protect your home. Simple faith,
home security.
Wait,
what the fuck are they talking about
with these contracts at home security as
you didn't want you to believe,
okay?
It's your only option.
What do they do?
They sign you a contract to do
what? Simple. Safe has no contracts.
None. You'll get award winning 24 seven
protection named best in the industry.
Oh, I see. Security
professionals watching,
ready to instantly send the
police and it's just fun.
They're not going to
go in and do something.
Jesus fucking Christ. I could do that.
There's gotta be another re Oh, I know.
They sit in the van. All right. My fault.
Sorry. Simple faith. Um, I just simple,
safe. I thought they were going
to tell you to have a home safe.
It's just 1499 per month.
That's less than half of what most
companies charge. Protect your home.
The smart way. Visit simple faith. Uh,
just a simple slave, safe birth.
Um, I'm assuming that slash Burr
I dunno, says simple,
safe. Burb, B U R r.com.
Today for an exclusive 10% offer,
it's gotta be slash bar has to be and get
a free key chain remote worth 25 bucks
only when you go to simple safe
bird.com. That's simple. Safe bird.com.
I hope that's right. I don't know.
That might be one and done. All right.
Blue Apron. Everybody. Ah, blue apron.
Blue Apron knows that when you
cook with incredible ingredients,
you make incredible meals.
So they set the highest quality standards
for their community of artisinal
supplies,
a supplier's family run farms,
fisheries and ranches,
whether it's Japanese ramen noodles,
wild caught Alaskan salmon
or heirloom tomatoes.
Blue Apron is bringing you the best. None
of that shit existed when I was a kid.
It's all because of the food network.
Like the level of options you now have
as a person to eat. You know what I mean?
It was fucking chipped beef on toast,
chicken noodle soup. Tuna casserole.
Yeah,
right. Cube steaks. These fucking
kids today, this is what they can eat.
These are kids in their struggling.
They can actually have so great blue
apron is you go from that horse shit to
Japanese ramen noodles,
wild caught Alaskan Salmon,
heirloom tomatoes.
There was one kid for less
than 10 bucks per meal.
Blue Apron delivers seasonal recipes
along with pre portioned ingredients to
make delicious home
cooked meals, um, variety,
new recipes or created each week by
blue apron culinary team and are not
repeated within a year.
Customize your recipes each
week based on your preferences.
Choose delivery options to fit your needs.
There's no weekly commitment.
So you only get deliveries
when you want them.
So if you've got a lady in your life,
you can cook her some meals.
If she fucking leaves you,
you can go right back to fucking eaten.
What the fuck did we used to have
steak ups? Oh, I'd love to stay calm.
I swear to God the last nine
periods of my school day,
I would be sitting there thinking about
the steak am I was going to make when I
got home.
Right?
Fry it up in the pan like someone in
those horse with the high heels and the
lipstick, right? And then you'd put it
on the white bread and watch the grease.
Turning to Greg, a little bit of ketchup
and some cheese, fucking phenomenal.
But anyways, back to blue apron.
Each meal comes with step by step,
easy to follow recipe cards
and pre portioned ingredients
and can be prepared at
40 minutes or less.
Check out this week's menu and get your
two meals for free with free shipping by
blue apron.com by going
to blue apron.com/bar you
will love how good it feels
and tastes to create incredible
home cooked meals with
blue apron. So don't wait.
That's blue apron.com/bird blue apron.
A better way to cook.
What do we got left here? We've got two
more left. Let's break it up. Okay, let's,
let's give you a break from my reading
out loud or my attempt at reading.
Uh, we'll go back to the fucking
podcast here. Uh, where did I go?
Where did I go? Where the fuck is the,
uh, the shit up? But uh, did it ed.
Um, all right. So should we get into the
reeds here for this week? Why don't we,
all right. Governor Gary
Jackson. Gary Johnson, sorry.
Governor Gary Johnson.
Hey Billy Shatner.
Billy fucking shit.
I'm not a libertarian.
I never said you were. I had never
been affiliated with any party.
I voted both parties and
for elections I voted in.
I've been eligible for six.
You sound like a blogger.
When you're going to criticize
a comedian going like,
I have a great sense of humor.
You know, I find this funny, I've,
I love this and blah, blah, blah. But
when I saw last night in a comedy club,
all right, so this guy has established
himself that he's open minded. All right?
Because he says,
so I'm not into the fringe candidates
and I don't buy into conspiracies.
I guess what I'm saying is I'm
not the typical Gary Johnson Fan.
Now what? Because you say so. I
guess what I'm saying is, well,
why don't you figure out what the fuck
you saying so you don't have to write x
to words in a sentence. Giving me more
opportunity to trip myself up, please.
All right. However, I am a fan of his,
and I think he could actually win
if he got on the, on the debates.
He's basically Bernie who I supported
for the most part. They just,
but I'm not a libertarian. Well, he
was a Democrat, right? Well, he was,
and then he became a libertarian, then
became a democrat. Is that how it worked?
I don't know.
I love Bernie Sanders.
Whoa.
Loved it. They align on 80% of
the issues. His running mate,
his former Massachusetts Governor,
Bill Weld,
Bill weld still in the game like
fucking Gordie Howe rested piece. Uh,
wondering what your thoughts on Gary
Johnson and also bill weld having lived in
the state, uh, when he was in office.
Below is a short campaign video
of the two of them. Well, I,
well what the fuck? I don't, I don't
know. I thought you were going to be,
tell me about them. I guess I was
supposed to watch this before.
Okay.
You Dude, you just gave
me homework. All right,
let's put this fucking thing in here
and we're going to try and watch it.
Oh Shit.
I'm running for Paris in it.
I'm running.
I'm running with them.
Jazzy music.
As the governor of New Mexico,
I vetoed wasteful spending 750 times,
cut taxes 14 times and left the snow.
Why is he so breathy
and $1 billion surplus
without raising taxes?
Massachusetts. How would I know
that? You just said that you did it.
Now how do I fuck? Can't fact check
all of that? I don't know. I mean,
it's exciting. We're going to
move the country forward. Music,
but a deep [inaudible].
Hi. Hi. I'm Jerry Johnson.
Um, I'm sure he's a great guy.
I'll look into it. I mean,
I like that you're giving me other options
because there's no fucking way I can
vote for Trump or for
Hillary, you know? Oh,
we all know the old bag's going to win it.
She's going to show up lipstick on her
teeth and that fucking maniacal wide eyed
fucking smile as she does.
Ah, she's going to carve this country
up even more. They are fucking evil.
I swear to God,
if Trump wasn't such a fucking dope,
if he wasn't such a dope, I actually
think he would be the lesser of two evils.
But I have to be honest with you,
there's no way to listen to Donald Trump
and not think about Martin Sheen in the
dead zone.
Can Somebody please Photoshop Trump
holding up the baby, you know,
and fucking what's his face?
Um,
Oh, Jesus Christ went walking up in the
balcony there or the dead fucking earth.
The birds are away, gentlemen.
Um, I have no idea, sir. I,
I commend you for,
uh,
being smart enough to not vote for
Trump or for Hillary. It's a, uh,
it's a really low point and
I wasn't a big Obama Fan,
but at least Obama, at least,
you know, the guy could speak
intelligently, you know,
after fucking eight years of
George Bush when that guy was,
that guy was like the presidential
version of me reading out loud.
All right.
Oh God.
There has to be so many other fucking
women out there that would meet,
make such great, honest
presidents. Do we really have?
Why does it have to be the one
with 52 pending felony counts?
All those Clinton's are
filter. Oh, Hillary Clinton,
she's dirtier than our husbands
Dick. Ah, right. Here we go.
Facial hair and little lady.
Hi, what's going on? I
forgot to do two weeks.
I'm actually in my garage
right now. All right. Score
score. Mickey. I dog.
Amazing. And yet, all right. Score.
You're paying too much for tickets
between all the mock ups and last minute
convenience judges, even friends at home
fees. What are you fucking kidding me?
You ended up paying courtside
prices for nosebleed seats.
Score big is here to change that.
Did you know that 40% of all
live event tickets go unsold?
And did you know that there's a place
to get these seats? A huge savings.
It's called score big scored big works
directly with your favorite teams and ad
is to get their unsold seats at
unpublished prices only with ScoreBig.
Can you name a ticket price
and be guaranteed to pay
below box office up to 60%
off. Here's what you do. One,
go to score big.com and download the new
score big APP on your iPhone and find
the event and seats.
You want to make an offer with score
pig's name a ticket price feature.
Three, get an instant answer and
save up to 60% on your tickets.
Never any fees and
shipping is always free.
You can count on unbeatable prices and
great seats when you're in and when
you're in grade teacher actually join
the game or the show all the more.
Next time you see any game or show,
go to score big first and see how much
you could save for the easiest way to
save on tickets. Download the
school big APP on your iPhone.
You already told us this shit in a promo
code [inaudible] at the checkout and
you'll save an extra 20 bucks off your
first ticket purchase. No, no iPhone,
no problem.
Get $20 off a online@scorebig.com that's
[inaudible] dot com promo code births
or big.com promo code. Okay? Okay.
I'll look away to his butt up.
Do Biondi Mija,
Andy's where I'm in a fucking go. Raj. Me,
I'm Dee D.
Get a small,
not I'll have them snug
and tight up on your ball.
No more sweaty. Not, oh they
come and cool colors. Your Lady,
you'll like them and maybe
she'll stop yard. Oh yeah,
can do one on the 4th of July.
All right, me undies, whether
you're wearing a suit or sweats,
you spend almost 24 hours a day in your
underwear unless you're a fucking animal.
But instead of making a statement like
Superman's pike under his everyday
clothes you're on the
way is probably boring.
The and days is here to
change that. Please include
all the fallen modal, modal.
Every pair of neon needs is made from
a sustainable source model of fabric
that's twice and soft is taught.
Nothing can describe the fit and feel of
me on these, but once you try them on,
you don't understand why they are called
the world's most comfortable underwear.
Yeah,
and if you don't love the first pair of
youngies there free no questions asked
me. Andy says dozens of styles and your
limited edition prints to help you make a
statement with your underwear was there.
Anyone can see them but not
remember superman. All right,
shipping is free and the US and Canada,
and you can save up to $8 a pair
with the me on the subscription plan.
Get the subscription or a single pair,
get 20% off your first order.
When you go to [inaudible] dot com slash
[inaudible] that's [inaudible] dot com
slash birth for 20% off
Yonnie's dotcom slash bird,
a deer,
big belly that Billy,
I'm a 17 year old guy who will be
starting college in the fall in the great
state of Massachusetts. Um,
Jesus starting at seven,
you must be turning 18 later on in the
year. Um, I'm always jealous of that.
I started,
I started college when I was 19.
I was already 19 and then I fucked up
my first four years and I was like a 23
year old sophomore, uh, my high schools.
Yeah.
A dress code allows guys to grow facial
hair and the last semester of senior
year, what, what foot
fucking school you going to?
So a few months ago I said, what
the hell? I'll give it a try.
Okay.
But you're only 17.
The last semester of your senior year,
you're getting giving yourself a hell of
a lot of time to grow. This shit said,
I ended up growing up growing a nice dark
full beard that seems to suit me well.
I got a lot of compliments for it.
Mostly from other guys,
but some from the ladies.
I remain single as I have
always been during this time.
I still have the beard now,
but I don't know whether I should keep
the beard or ditch it and arrive at
college.
Clean Shaven.
Do you think it's a good or bad idea to
make my first impression while sporting
a beer in terms of the ladies,
is the beard assign of manliness
and strength or more of a turnoff?
I don't fucking, I got to ask Nia. Hang
on a second. Jesus Christ. How that,
why the fuck would I know?
You know, I always thought
Dan Fouts was sexy. Hang on.
All right. You happy she was sleeping? I
just, I didn't know if she was sleeping.
I was fucking, I've never happened
there. All right, well there you go.
So you fucked the whole thing up and
cleaned up and then I woke her up. Um,
anyway, I do it. I don't fucking know.
But you're saying that you're not,
you're not allowed to have facial
hairs at this fucking school. You Go.
Was that like a type Typo or something?
My, all, my high school's not college.
My high school's dress code allows guys
to grow facial hair in the last semester
of senior year. Oh, okay. I thought
it was a scene at college. Um,
we'll look to when I was a kid,
the only reason to grow a beard was so
you could buy booze or get served when
you were still under rage. You
know, whether women like it or not,
I have no fucking idea.
Um,
okay.
I don't,
I don't know.
Yeah,
go there fucking clean shaven
and then, uh, you know,
get a little scruff going.
Assumption. I don't know this,
this is like a cosmo question.
I have no fucking, do they,
is it a sign of manliness?
I have no idea. I mean,
if you grow it too quickly,
it might be a sign of a hairy back and
that might take you out of the game.
Some women might be like,
Oh,
my dad had a beard in the subconsciously
that gets into them, you know? Oh yeah.
That reminds me of feeling safe with
my dad. And next thing you know,
they're blowing. Yeah. Then they're like,
what the fuck? That just what happened?
Right.
I don't know.
Let's move on to the next question. That
was a hard one. I had no fucking idea.
All right. Cheating Bitch,
girlfriend out g is there.
Hey you red face.
Fuck.
I Dunno why I find that
shit's so endearing. Um,
showed you what the fuck's wrong with me.
All right.
About a month ago I
started dating this lady.
She seemed really quiet in pretty
innocent. After about a week I realized,
I just pictured that woman in that Vince
Vaughn movie, the a wedding crashers. Um,
whoever that actress was fucking
hilarious and that will be. Anyways,
after about a week I realized that
her last boyfriend was a total freak,
like Jean shorts and shit.
Fuck you mean freak like a Weirdo.
What was fucking, you know,
having threesomes with this chick
anyways, like Jean shorts and shit. Fuck.
So I did my best to just ignore that and
have fun together. I was, in my opinion,
a great boyfriend to her.
I took her on a lot of dates and it
seemed like everything was perfect.
And this was my first girlfriend.
I'm only 16 and pretty introverted.
So having a girlfriend was a big step for
me. Yeah, that's huge. Good fuel, man.
Anyways, after a few weeks, she
started acting weird. One day at lunch,
she told me that her old weird boyfriend
and her had sex before school that day
and they also had sex a couple of
other times while we were going out.
I didn't know what to say
and it really fucked me up.
She even said it wasn't her fault and
I shouldn't be mad. Oh, you know what?
I was actually going to give this girl
props for being mature enough to own up
to what the fuck she did.
And then she said that don't be mad at me.
Um,
after a fight,
I told her to fuck.
I told her to fuck and left. I think
fuck off. That's what you meant,
because she's already fucking,
dude. You don't need to tell her.
You should have told him to to less
fuck two x ne on the [inaudible].
Um, she then started saying
that it was my fault.
I don't know what I did wrong. Oh, you
poor bastard and you're only 16 years old,
right? So you didn't, you didn't
have your deflector shields up.
Is that what it is? Did you say you were
16 right? The fuck was that? I'm only 16.
Okay. So now everyone knows that
school because high school is bullshit.
Um, I know I, I'm now known by everyone,
including my family as the guy
who got cheated on this pitch.
Not only made me feel like shit,
but also kind of ruined the whole
aspect of finding a nice girl.
I don't trust them and feel as
if I will never move on. Yeah.
These are the catastrophic thoughts
you have when you're 60, uh,
because your world is small. You still
living at home with your parents.
You go to school,
you see the same fucking cunts every day,
and you feel like the
walls are closing in.
All of these feelings are
100% normal. Um, how do you,
how do you move on after
being fucked over like that?
The only things I've done is got
a job and started lifting weights.
Maybe then when school starts again,
I can show up shredded and do better
next year. There you go. I like it.
Turn a negative into a positive. Um,
here's the thing. You're a nice guy,
right? You're a nice
guy. Uh, well, you know,
so that means there's the Nice woman
out there that balances you out,
right? If you're a dick, there's
plenty of clients out there,
but you're a nice guy. So
what I would do is, uh,
I would thank my lucky stars that that
fucking woman is out of your life.
You know, she's totally
fucked up. All right.
She's going to go back to the Jean Short
guy and they're going to fuck before
school and they're going to do
all of this other shit. And, um,
who gives a fuck? I don't
understand how, like,
I don't know how, there's no reason
for you just me listening to this,
why you should feel bad about yourself.
I get, you know, I got cheated on,
you know,
it's happened to everybody and uh,
it makes you just more feel stupid
is what it is. You know what I mean?
So I'm trying to count the amount
of times that's happening to me.
The first girl I was with was
like fucking way older than me.
I went from like zero to 90
miles an hour in fucking,
yeah. She ended up cheating on me and
breaking up a fucking marriage. And,
uh, I did, I, oh,
I remember how I didn't even know.
I ended up running into the wife of the
guy that she cheated with and then they
were broken up and she told me,
and
I just, my judgment, my thought
was I just went like, Huh.
You know?
And there was a lot in that
because it just let me
know that, uh, you know,
I just thought guys did shit like that,
you know,
I thought we would just the fucking
animals. And it was just like, wow.
So she was doing that and then
come home and smile. Yeah.
And that fucked me up for
a long fucking time. Yeah.
You know what an I didn't trust women,
you know, and I started lifting weights.
Did I write this thing 20 years ago?
What the fuck now? Um, yeah dude,
this is the deal. You know, it's
going to take time to get over it,
but you know you're going to meet
somebody nice. And I think, yeah,
you're in the prime of your life.
You throw the weights around a little bit,
you show up fucking shredded,
right?
Yeah.
And then you show you,
I show up in September and just
start chatting up the women.
And this is the thing too. Women
love a fucking, they love a project,
you know, so you can use the fact that
this woman cheated on you, that Oh,
you know, I have problems,
trust and fucking women and
now they'll just, they'll,
they'll be coming at Ya. He beat them
off with a fucking stick. All right.
Yeah Dude. Fuck that. This is the
thing. You don't have a letter.
Anytime anything bad happens in life,
you don't have it. You don't let it,
you know, there's two things you
can do. You can either just fucking,
I don't know. I, I, I view like that
those types of thoughts. Like, you know,
when you watch like bugs bunny and
they would have like that, wait,
that just said one ton on it. I view
like that. That's what that thought is.
All right. And you're standing
next to a fucking pool.
All right?
And the thing's got a chain around it
and either just fucking let it go to the
bottom of the pool itself.
Or you stick your head in the chain and
wrap it around your neck and you let it
take it down. And then you just down
there in the bottom of the pool. You know,
why would you do that? Fuck
it. Fuck you. Fuck her.
Just let that whole thing,
I'm not saying don't deal with it,
but you got to turn it into a positive,
which is what you seem to be doing fucking
workout and chat up a bunch of women.
This is think maybe, uh, you know,
start your list of fucking requirements.
You test,
you lock the door test to maybe to
try to get a good one. Uh, you know,
women always say, find a good finding
a good, a good man's hard to find.
Soza good woman.
So what this woman did is a help
you start early on a checklist,
because I didn't start a checklist
for a long fucking time, you know,
I was well into my thirties and I was
still just like, hey, you want to fuck
every thought, every thing
you do, everything on my list
is checked off, you know?
All right, here we go. All time
underrated quarterbacks. You'll be fine.
You'll be fine. Shake it off. It's
fucking your fault. That's Atlanta.
That poor woman, she's got a lot of issues
and a bit, she's has a terrible father,
you know? So in a way you can look
at it like that because you know,
she is young and immature, but if she
continues to live her life that way,
that is, that is a bad fucking
road to go on. You know,
that's fucking white symphony.
Dale's of the red wine,
gray teeth with the fucking and tramp
stamp. She's going to go down that one
and the piece of shit,
guys,
she's going to meet Jean shorts
will be the least of our problems.
I hope that doesn't happen to her
either. But, uh, anyways, here we go.
All time underrated.
Qbs dear Billy White shoes.
Very nice reference.
Billy White shoes,
Johns of the Houston Oilers and
the Atlanta Falcons. Alright,
bye friends.
Tear me apart from being a
huge Vinny Testaverde fan.
I truly love the man and feely flies under
the radar as an all time quarterback.
Maybe not hall of fame caliber,
but someone who could have won a super
bowl if he didn't have to face Elway.
Tarell Davis in the 1998
Denver Bronco Machine.
Well,
you realize what you're saying,
that he could have been a championship
if he didn't have to play the best team
in the league. Well, I
mean, yeah, well shit.
San Diego Padres could be
a fucking dynasty if it
wasn't for all the other fee.
The fucking 1998 Yankees
or the late nineties Yankees.
Right? I don't know. Anyways,
he played 22 seasons and in his final
season with season with the Carolina
Panthers,
he won his first game after only being
on the team for three fucking days at the
age of 43.
He was definitely a bad ass.
Nobody could be in that backyard playing
horseshoes with this son and then out
of football in two days later be under
under center and fucking winning a game.
Like he did that like I think three times
in his career. He was sort of like a,
maybe it just happened once.
I Dunno,
but I just feel like he was officially
retired at least once, if not twice.
And he was in the back yard
eating a fucking Burger,
having a course light and all of a sudden,
Hey Bernie,
this is the fucking whatever
Seattle Seahawks calling or Tampa.
But where did he play
Tampa. The jets. Carolina.
That's a great one. Cleveland.
And he played with Cleveland.
It was at Bernie Coza again, I get
confused my older age. Let's look up.
Oh Vinny Testaverde Vinay.
Then he had the fucking veal.
All right, you guys want
to hear a great, uh,
you guys wanna hear a
great fucking La Story.
I went out to an Italian
restaurant the other day, right?
And we sitting up front near the bar and
it was too loud and one of the guys I
was eating with us,
cause this is too fucking loud,
let's try to get a table in the back.
So they end up hooking us up with a table
in the back and as I'm going to walk,
you know to the back, one of the
guys there up to bar, he goes, yeah,
go in the back.
You know,
you can barely hear yourself
thinking just the way he said it.
I can't remember what he said.
He said something along those lines.
Super Italian guy and the way he said
it and the fact that I was moving as I
went past him,
I felt like I was in that tracking scene
in Goodfellas when they were showing
all those characters, you know, get
the papers, get the papers, a guy,
it guy took care of that thing,
right?
Literally it gave me like
a shock the way he said it.
So I said to one of the guys that we
were, I was having dinner with. I said,
Hey Michael, Jesus Christ.
Go. That guy just made me
feel like I was in Goodfellas.
Classic La Story and why it's
so amazing to live out here.
He goes, do you know who that
is? And I said, no. He goes,
that's the guy who
played Johnny roast beef
and then I fucking looked at him
again. I was like, oh my God,
it's Johnny Roast beef.
One of the greatest pieces fucking acting
I've ever seen is when he's trying to
explain a way that pink Cadillac and he
starts to stop and then then he starts
to talk and then he
stops and actually had,
I talked to him about it for a second
and he just laughed. He said, one said,
basically said, when a man is scary
as Jimmy, the gent is yelling at you.
He goes, you don't say a fucking
word. Remember that? No, it, it's,
it's in my grandmother's name. What's
the matter with me? It's a matter of me.
You're going to get us all fucking pinch.
That's why some matter with you,
what's the matter with you?
Take it back,
take it back at the fuck that look
on his fucking face and he goes to,
he just keeps going. I'm sorry. I,
yeah,
I'm sorry.
What did I tell you?
What the fuck? What did I tell? I
fucking love that seat. So anyways,
um, Vinny Testaverde, here we go.
Be any folk in test of early Ovi.
Um,
here we go. Vinny Testaverde. Let's
see. It was him with the panthers.
He's 52 years old. I swear to God. I bet
he's still in shape. And if you fucking,
if you, you know, if you call
them up right now, if you
called them up right now,
he could give you a decent audit.
What the fuck?
87 to 92 we played for
the Tampa Bay Buccaneers.
93 to 95 he played for the
Cleveland browns 96 97,
the Baltimore Ravens 98 to 2003,
the New York jets,
which is how I remember him as a jet.
2000 for the Dallas cowboys.
2005, he goes back to the jets.
2006, he played for my patriots.
I don't even remember that.
2007 he played for the panthers.
20 year fucking career. 21
seasons. Wow. Two time pro bowler.
96 98 Heisman trophy,
86,
uh,
Davy O'Brien bump up a buzz Sammy Bar,
trophy sportsman of the year,
86 let's see,
tds verse,
interceptions.
This is what fucked him
over the 275 touchdowns,
267 interceptions.
Wasn't somebody wrapped like that
in incomplete, like Testaverde. Uh,
but he didn't say intercepted,
but he threw for 46,233 yards
back in the day, you know,
for the most part when you actually,
they could cover receivers before Jim say
changed all the fucking rules cause he
couldn't beat the Patriots,
but that's okay.
I know the ball was underinflated
let's kick them out of football.
Passing rating. Passive Passer Rating,
75.0 all right. Well yeah. Okay.
Those are great. Fuck. You
know, do you play 20 seasons?
But he did throw a lot
of pics. So anyways, um,
where he's the oldest
quarterback to ever start.
And when a pro football game
older than George Blanda.
Well, I thought George Blend, maybe
he was just kicking at that point.
Everybody always reverts back to the days,
his days in Tampa and Cleveland.
But I'd argue that those Tampa years
where some of the worst pro squads ever to
try it on a football onto a
football field. Yeah, absolutely.
You can't blame somebody for that.
You know, it's like Joey Harrington,
he goes and he fucking plays
for uh, the lions, you know,
odd. Right out of the gate. There's no
way as bad. He's as bad as he looked.
Those lion teams were fucking horrible.
I'm not saying that the guy would
have played in the league or whatever,
but you know,
for the longest time if you got
drafted by the lions or the browns as,
as a quarterback,
that was a fucking death sentence,
which is another brilliant
move that John Elway made.
Cause when he got drafted by
the Baltimore Colts, he's like,
I'm not fucking going there,
getting the shit kicked out of
me and I'll be out of football.
I mean that almost
happened to Troy Aikman.
Okay.
Troy Aikman when he got
drafted by the fucking cowboys.
So got the living shit kicked out of him
his first few years. If that continued,
I mean, that guy, he would
have been out of football.
But fortunately the Herschel Walker trade
went down with Jimmy Johnson App boys.
Right. They got that fucking, uh,
all those 300 pounders in front
of them. I Dunno. Anyways,
let's plow ahead here. Uh,
he said as a patriots fan,
I'd like your thoughts on him.
Are My friends right?
Saying he was just an average
quarterback at best? No fucking way.
No way though. He was, he was w uh,
well you don't play for 20
fucking years. Okay. He was,
he was above way above average,
I think. I think he was a,
he's not a, I wouldn't say he's one of
the greats, but he was definitely a, uh,
he was a really good quarterback.
You know, he wasn't like, um,
what does he, if he was, if
he was an average Qb at best,
you don't play for 20 years,
be an average unless you Steve
to Berg and just some out.
You just look so great with
a headset and a clipboard.
People just wanted you around. He was
like the David Hasselhoff, you know,
a fucking quarterbacks.
It just,
I think you sold more tickets
because he never had his helmet on.
The ladies could come down and look
at them. Look up Steve to Berg here.
Steve to Berg.
All right.
Oh yeah, the David Hasselhoff.
He looks like he's looked like,
you know,
whenever they had those coming of age
movies and you got the nerd who wants to
date the fucking cheerleader,
but she's dating the guy who was
just a complete fucking Dick. Uh,
he had those, those
level good looks, dude.
I'm telling you right now. Look this
guy up. That's fucking hilarious.
He looks like he saw
Baywatch played number 17 on.
Now we got this, this, you know what?
This is actually morphed into the
degraded NFLs greatest journeyman.
I'm going to look this up.
Okay,
great. Is God, I love the Internet.
I love that somebody made a page
about this shit. Best Nfl journeymen,
the seven most unkillable
journeyman quarterbacks.
I love the Internet because of shit
like this and all the fucking free porn.
All right, here we go. Um,
there's a good chance that
at one time or another,
your team's hopes were riding on
Ryan Fitzpatrick, Brian Hoyer,
or one of the NFLs other well
traveled signal call is, Oh,
don't be all just new guys. Come
on. All right. Ryan Fitzpatrick,
Brian Fitzpatrick, a played for
the Texans, the titans, the rams,
the bangles, the jets,
and the bills. All right.
Josh mccown. Uh, I've, uh, Brian Hoyer.
Matt Cassel.
Okay.
A castle. Matt Flynn, the perennial
backups. I'll come on, man.
Tim Tebow. Now this, this
was done by some youngster.
You got to have Steve to Bergen.
Then you've got Vinny Testaverde
journeymen NFL players
who just won't go away.
Do I have to type in all time?
Is that what I have to do?
I think I got to type in all
time. Come on, man. You've
got to, if, if the, if Steve,
the burst not on your fucking list.
Yeah.
These not on your fucking list.
Journeymen quarterback. All right,
we'll just go Wikipedia.
Oh, this is depressing. I
thought it was gonna be great.
Jt O'sullivan played for 12
professional teams during his career.
You know what? I bet in his
man cave, he should, they,
the NFL should give them
all 12 of those helmets.
All 12 of those fucking helmets.
Why am I all wrapped up in the
fucking court here? What's going on?
All right,
here we go.
This is what happens when you fucking lay
down on a couch and there's why is, um,
JT O'sullivan,
he played on no less than 11 to NFL teams.
Oh, professionals. Okay. So,
and then he also played
for the Saskatchewan rough
riders and the Frankfurt
Galaxy.
Chris Chandler holds the record for
starting a game for the highest number of
different NFL teams with
eight. Oh, so he started, okay.
There's no accepted definition
or threshold at which a
person is regarded as a
journeyman quarterback. Um, the term
is descriptive rather than definitive.
David Craig enjoyed 11 s stable careers
with the Seahawks before leaving.
Let's see, Mark Rypien notable
examples. Here we go. Here we go.
Trent Dilfer, Brad Johnson, rich Gannon.
Where the fuck is Steve debarge
notable journeymen quarterbacks?
Come on,
come on.
All right. You know, I'm trying to
look up Steve debarge. I'm sorry guys.
This whole podcast just you just listened
to me surf the fucking Internet now to
people still say surf the internet or
was that from the 90 [inaudible] I'm old
already.
He's 62 years old.
He played for the San Francisco 40 niners
from 1977 to 1980 the Broncos from 81
to 83 the Buccaneers from 84 to 87
the chiefs from 88 to 91 back to the
Buccaneers.
92 93 the Miami Dolphins,
1993 he was out of fucking football in
94 he was out of football in 95 out of
football, 96 out of football,
97 and then what the fuck?
1998 he's back. What? The dirty birds,
the Atlanta Falcons who upset
the 15 and one Minnesota Vikings.
Right.
And then went to the fucking super bowl,
one of the most forgettable
super bowls of all fucking time.
And the Denver Broncos repeated or
that was the last fucking game of John
Elway's career. All right.
TDS, two interceptions.
He had a 196 touchdowns
versus 204 interceptions.
He threw for 34,000, 241 yards.
And as a higher QB rating,
did Vinny Testaverde it's
74.2, right? Or was he 75?
I don't fucking remember.
Steven Lee. Roy De Berg.
There you go. That's, that's my, um,
yeah,
that's my vote.
You know,
it's funny like I bet he doesn't have a
lot of problems walking or anything like
that cause he's got,
so he has a low miles on that odometer
as far as like actually playing in the
phone.
I'm not trying to insult the guy here.
I'm just saying like if he was a car,
you know,
it'd be like those all original
miles. It'd be a, yeah. Yeah.
He sat in a garage with a fucking
clipboard for all those years. All right.
That's the podcast for
this, uh, this 4th of July.
I hope you guys all have a happy and a
safe one. All right. You fucking drunks.
I know it's a fireworks and
it's supposed to be fun,
but yet all day our explosives
don't be that person.
And one of those youtube fucking videos
of like top 10 stupidest fucking moose
done with fireworks.
Did you see that fucking guy?
He actually took like a mortar
or some shit, put it on his head.
I don't know if he thought
it was going to take off.
He literally blew himself up. His
friends go. You don't understand.
There was nothing left of him.
It was nothing left to help.
You know?
They just showed up and there was,
there was like a belt buckle and
like a shoelace. He was gone.
So please don't do that to yourself.
All right. All right, clay out.
Um, all right, that's the podcast.
You guys have a great week.
I will check in with dia.
Go fuck yourselves. I'll
check in on you on Thursday.
All right.